so when you go into d5 what exactly are
you guys doing you're taking
bitcoin that you own and well ether and
earnings that's what i
want okay i'm i'm a i'm an investor so
there must be many other investors like
me i've made my decision to three to
five percent allocation
probably as you as you've snuck out of
me i'm going to be moving it up because
you're right gold's not doing anything
for me
well three plus five is eight not five
so you could get rid of all the gold
could get to ten
okay all right but you know we're bound
by certain covenants just
how we manage the operating company 10 i
feel like is on the upper bound of most
conservative investors right so it still
fits within the
kind of bands if you will if you're a
conservative investor most of your focus
is outside of crypto
yeah one to ten percent is kind of the
ban is up there
institutional investor 10 is up there of
course right now that number
for the big guys is three percent
they're happy and they they want
bitcoin they haven't gotten past that
yet
bitcoin is the property the digital
asset they want
um and they want to store value store
value and you've been right on that
can't deny that okay it's a it's a
volume
we might have to roll the tape back if
they have to erase that but
my whole point is the the it it has
inherent volatility but imagine
so here's my thoughts about d5 okay i've
got the vol i know i'm going to be up
up and down 38 a year that's what it's
been historically right
so we're seeing that we've had a crazy
vol right here we're literally recording
this on a day that uh it's been down 40
in a month okay so so let's say in in my
case my d5 company of which i'm a large
shareholder now
i say to the guys look let's put a bunch
of crypto on our balance sheet
all right i'm going to own a third of
that balance sheet or whatever i own the
balance sheet
i want you to loan that out and get me
between a four and a half and an eight
percent yield
now of course i have to mark to market
the change in value because it's going
up and down
but i'm kind of agnostic because i'm
owning it as property i don't
really care because it's an allocation
let's say it's five percent
it's gonna stay at five i'll change it
every quarter adding or taking away from
it
but i want you to loan it out there so
the whole
operation the defy operation is to start
doing these contracts for me on an ai
basis
so it can go look to the market see what
the spreads are on all these different
opportunities i don't want to get too
complicated with it
it's basically yield for me what you're
just going to do for me and then
others that are interested like i am on
taking their asset
and imagine if i could have over these
years had a five percent yield on my
gold
that would have been incredible well i
can on my crypto so
that's really what i'm doing in d5 and i
think i've got the best team in north
america everybody says that but
i'm backing this team because i've done
a lot of due diligence on them
and i think you know in the next few
months
that will become part of our portfolio
with a yield metric to it
so because what you're basically saying
is uh you're going to keep the assets
denominated in the asset
right so uh let's say just freezing
things you have
a hundred eth you put that in you want
eight percent so now you're going to end
the year with 108 eth
staying in regardless of did the price
go up or down i might go back to fiat to
just pay some expenses
but i'm going to stay in eath on that
balance sheet and you as a shareholder
go with me in the share price as my
assets grow
do you think that this is a really
important piece that i think the
traditional world hasn't woken up to yet
sounds like you're now
getting there is um once you leave
fiat into crypto yeah you don't go back
i don't want to go back
okay why would i well i don't know you
tell me how do you think about it right
so
you've got 100 of your assets you've
said i'm gonna take three i'm gonna put
it into crypto yeah
uh maybe that goes up maybe it doesn't
whatever but let's just say it's three
to five percent whatever the allocation
is
once you put that into crypto why are
you not going back well the reason i
would come back out let's say
let's say our covenant is a max on 10
which is that most institutions that is
max arena okay all right so 10 is the
max allocation because because if you're
going
you know you basically if you have lps
or you have other shareholders or you
have
other constituents you've told them you
have a covenant of diversification and
it might be 10
whatever it is but it's not much higher
than that so when you get to 12
the end of a quarter in your crypto
you're going to trim back to fiat
you're going to go back to 10 percent or
or maybe you know
um and then you just sit in the weeds
waiting for correction and you buy back
up to ten percent i've you know i've
been buying
like i mean you bought the dip well it's
it's
it's not really a dip it's maintaining
the three percent waiting right
yeah no i'm saying the dip in the price
i know i know but it but to me it's okay
we're 2.4 and we said we're at three buy
up to three
because we've had a correction you can't
call that that's a correction
well i mean look in 2017 there was what
six over 30 percent i think right there
was two 40
draw down so uh it doesn't feel good
right we don't know what the asset
draws down but it's not uh atypical for
the kind of historical bull runs right
right which
again if you tell in the traditional
world uh hey there's gonna be two forty
percent drawdowns but you're gonna go up
20 x in a year
they're like i'm out well yeah like i'm
out of this
but but in this case um you end up with
more coin after that correction
and then you're out loaning it out and
you're getting your and with that
volatility you just got 200 basis points
more yield
people don't understand vol is good for
yield it's not good for your stomach
but it actually helps you mine yield
from your crypto
and so when you understand those smart
contracts and how it's being loaned out
um and i'm getting way more
sophisticated so i look at it now
with my team saying okay you know you
could even put leverage on this if you
want which we don't
but i think that's a crazy chicken move
but you could really goose your hands
why are you only targeting four and a
half to eight percent some of these can
pay
twenty percent thirty percent what's
your duration what duration well that's
why i'm asking you right
is it just you're saying hey i wanna be
able to earn the four and a half to
eight percent forever
and the twenty to thirty percent's only
there for a couple of weeks or a couple
of months like
how do you think about yield verse
duration so what we don't have is a long
history of what that curve on duration
looks like
you just don't have it we're all
pioneers in this and because i'm a bond
guy i've been a bond guy for decades and
so what i look at is duration and
quality
you don't you can't work with that yet
we don't know so i said look let's keep
our contract short let's understand
the change in the deltas let's
understand you know how inefficient the
market is when there's a lot of
volatility let's just
gather our own data keep our powder dry
let's only loan out 50 of our positions
until we understand it works
and i should also disclose i'm working
with some of the larger
corporate defy guys i've opened accounts
to manage some of my company's balance
sheets i'm putting up to five percent of
our
fiat currency into a strategy like this
on our balance sheets
i don't talk about that too much but i'm
letting you know i'm saying guys
we're in you know let's have an
operating company it's sitting with you
know
30 million dollars in cash let's put
million and a half
into this strategy we'll open an account
you'll understand it works you're the
treasury let me show you how it works
how i'm doing it
let's disclose to uh if they're private
we just have to disclose to our lp's
what we're doing
i haven't anybody said to me no i don't
want that everybody wants to learn
so instead of making nothing on our cash
which we're basically under inflation
we're losing money on our cash
you know we're picking up we're doing
better than four and a half that was a
few weeks ago when coin was very stable
now like today you can get seven eight
nine
as you know mm-hmm so it's not
impossible and so i think
i only put five percent of the company's
assets why not do more if
it's just yield you're not taking the
price risk necessarily in terms of
that's the goal
because the compliance
departments are all in that let's tiptoe
in
you you know the the concern it's it it
really is a three percent number right
now
there are some at five but the here's
the thing that everybody should
understand that
because i live in this world the
potential is
huge you've got less than one percent
of global corporations even thinking
about crypto right now
so as time passes and they see examples
of what i'm doing and others are doing
and they start to tiptoe in you're
talking about
billions of dollars that are sitting on
balance sheets making nothing and so
it's going to become
that's good and bad news because the
more money goes into that the less yield
you're going to be making there's going
to be a lot of competition
and so but right now i'm tiptoeing
through the tulips you know
almost double-digit yields i think it
comes down commensurate with the
volatility so you here's the thing to
understand i don't want to get too
complicated but let's say when you put a
lot of bitcoin on your balance sheet
you're gonna have vol you're gonna have
volatility the criticism of tesla we've
been watching
they showed on cnbc today all the
balance sheets that have
you know crypto on it they're all down
because people think oh what was me
they've got crypto it's gonna affect
their balance sheet
it does but at the same time they're
loaning it out
if they're smart and they're bringing in
yield that they never used to make on
their cash
so over time when people understand this
it'll offset it